there is one scene that everyone's gonna
be talking about when you are in the
bodega singing Salinas dreaming of you
[Music]
you know what
Blair how about you get the snacks we'll
meet you outside
no talk to me about what it was like
filming that scene how much fun was that
of the greatest thing ever it might
favor it was there like do you want us
to send you this song so you can
memorize it and I was like really do you
think I need to memorize that Thom
I mean Selena like I grew up with Selena
recipes love that that woman changed so
many lives and so to be able to sing
that song the Bodega was really dope
they have the clearance of that whoa we
were like sweating it we're like ladies
please I get Claire boy I had all the
fun I mean I think you know part of the
reason when you're watching the film
you're having fun it's because we were
having fun when we were doing it and
that scene it was probably it was one of
many where I was like do not ruin the
tape do andhe like do not laugh don't
laugh do not ruin this seeing Lena when
I was a kid and and just loving that
whole movie and and crying because of
that movie but that scene was really
special because we all get to sing
together and be silly and everybody's
had that moment with your girlfriends
were you just like singing get lost in
it you're like wait what are we doing no
are we we're not Selena um so yeah it
was really fun to shoot how did that
seem come about was that inspired by
true events yes I was in a grocery store
and I was heartbroken and I was looking
at a bunch of rotisserie chickens and
actually Adele Someone Like You came on
there
[Music]
you
and I just started crying in the grocery
store and I was like well this is this
should be a something this is ridiculous
um and then when we were putting the
movie together it just like there's just
like a flavor to Celina that just like
it adds to the film and I loved it a lot
I love Celina so much that I add her
music was was amazing
was it like watching the girls film that
seamed together give me some
behind-the-scenes secrets oh my god it
wasn't me it was so we I was like
stifling laughter because they're just
like they just went for it so hard in
this bodega and it's like a grand space
because we were literally in like a very
small bodega so I'm literally sitting in
an aisle between like cat food and candy
bars watching them film Missy it was it
was amazing that always gonna be the
song what are some behind-the-scenes
secrets about what it was like filming
that that's true it was not always
supposed to be the song we had a couple
other options it was either like boys to
men we had a couple other like things
that we were kind of joined with but
Selena went out of course cuz that is a
great thing why wouldn't you choose
anything else
Selena always always no contest
you